what the vaccine
enables people to go along with more
easily is the idea of a health passport
or vaccine passport and that passport
becomes a gateway to a digital id that's
connected to your ability to participate
in society so it is the beginning of a
social credit system it is the back door
into a social credit system like what we
see in china which is effectively
totalitarian under theirs
it is not to say that people in china
can't live a relatively good life
but they are bound by this they have to
say the right things not say the wrong
things they have to spend time with the
right people not spend time with the
wrong people they have to you know do
all these kinds of things to manage your
social credit score or they find that
their ability to
use their their resources their money or
whatever to take a trip or to get on a
train or to get on a plane or whatever
it happens to be can be pretty severely
curtailed um it can be very easily
expanded to the point where depending on
your social credit score things cost
more or less for you could be a you know
a discount rate if you have a good
propaganda score um because that's how
you raise your social credit scores
behaving the way the government tells
you to and sometimes literally by
watching propaganda videos on your
device and so if you participate in this
they can make it to where your groceries
cost 50 less and if you refuse to
participate in this or if you go against
it they might cost 50 more and so they
can really put a lot of social leverage
on people
and also they ban things like people
getting together in large numbers unless
it's government sanctioned and there's
government representatives there
watching it it is the back door to
something far worse the vaccine itself
whether it's absolutely worthless
whether it's slightly valuable whether
it's
extremely valuable turns out to be
irrelevant to this question
the
the vaccine is not going to end the
pandemic because the pandemic is being
used to
install social control i'm holding up
right now my cell phone and people
constantly are saying to me
i don't want a vaccine passport because
people will know where i am
you know what this cell phone does it
transmits every minute where i am to a
slew of people
not just hackers
but my credit card company my bank
somebody does open table and makes
reservations at rest they know where i
am all the time this thing is a gps it
tracks me constantly
i would worry about that area of privacy
more i mean i'm on board to say we gotta
protect your privacy but the vaccine
passport is like
a one percent risk relative to
your credit card your cell phone
um your uber uh registration uh what
facebook knows about you i mean my god
there's like
there's a hundred different companies
right now that know
everything about me uh where i
look on the web where i go and we
haven't done anything about that